hey guys it is the third of februari my
name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games what news good for you so
like every Monday we had a bunch of news
rolling over the weekend and the slice
of that involved new details about
PlayStation now several lucky users
snagged themselves beta access but as of
now they'll know exactly what games
they'll actually be able to play through
it and get ready to don their excitement
or disappointment hat respectively the
first party games the beta gamers can
look forward to our kill zone 3
puppeteer and shadow of the colossus the
rest of the lineup consists on third
party games puppet yo Darksiders to MX
vs atv alive disgaea for ninja gaiden 3
and shut up that may seem like a pretty
limited selection but this is just for
the beta and not the full selection of
games that the service will offer up in
the long term as we already learnt
PlayStation now will only be supporting
ps3 titles at the moment but there's
that whole room adem ulation thing to
look forward to FPS 1 and 2 games are
you thing are you in on the beta and
what do you think of the current game
offering let me know Ubisoft spent today
abandoning their watch dogs trademark
and yes you did hear that correctly the
publisher ditched the main trademark
that it held for the upcoming open world
game but we should mention early that
this doesn't mean the game is cancelled
Ubisoft's New Year Eve's glamour himself
filed an express abandonment request to
drop the principal watch dogs trademark
which covers game software and
electronic game programs and the weird
part is this happen three days after you
be got themselves an extension on the
trademark well that's not the weird part
is all the weird part another part that
certainly classifies as weird is that
you be are still holding watch dogs
trademark spot online computer games
toys TV shows theatrical performances
and clothing so you ain't no get your
watchdogs game but if you want to
snuggle up in watch dogs theme
jammies with an aiden pearce action
figure you'll probably be all good let
me know what you think this means for
the games last up sony put their two
cents into the 1080p 60fps debate so i
guess that's something i get to talk
about again yay well last week Microsoft
was arguing that the debate is overblown
and rarely makes a difference so any
record performance does matter and
that's probably because they've been
finding themselves on the winning side
for most of these frame rate
competitions according to Sony is down
to listening to depths they've also said
they're creating the next-gen console
that's ultimately easiest to develop or
interesting since the xbox 360 was
typically thought of as easier to
develop for down the ps3 let me know if
technical performance has factored into
your console buying decisions either in
the comments down below or you can do so
on my Twitter where I'm at Jess McDonald
those are most of the things that I
happy today but you should have dropped
me your favorite stories and I'll tell
you about the kinect distinguishing
between man and beast on Friday free
tomorrow